are you looking for
a change of scenery are you tired of
boring old earth how would you like
a new home away from home really far
away from home
like outside our solar system farm
what exoplanet would suit us best
are there any pros
and more importantly what are the cons
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we settled on an exoplanet
an exoplanet is a planet outside our
solar system
as of march 2020 we've discovered
over 4 000 different ones
so it sounds like we have some options
for our interplanetary house hunt
but we do have a must on our list that
could
make or break the deal whichever
exoplanet we settle on
must be located in something called a
habitable zone
being in a habitable zone means that the
planet orbits
around a star kind of like our sun
the big perk here is that water on this
planet
will stay liquid fun fact we humans
need water to survive so this
is a biggie so we got in touch with our
space realtor
and they've picked out a cozy little
exoplanet for us to settle on
tea gardens star b
tea garden oh that sounds like a nice
neighborhood
to sweeten the deal this exoplanet is
only
12 and a half light years from earth
which means it's
one of the closest exoplanets we've
found so far
it has an earth similarity index
of 0.95 which is the highest of all
exoplanets to date
tea gardens star b is a major contender
for
a settlement but before we rent the
moving ships
let's see what we're dealing with
t-gardens
star b orbits an m-type star
like our sun only a lot smaller and
cooler
it is located 40 times closer to its
star
than the earth is to the sun the
infrared radiation from the m-type star
would be absorbed by the ice instead of
being reflected
that means water vapor and carbon
dioxide can
also absorb and trap infrared radiation
so what does this mean for you well you
won't
freeze to death so that's a win in our
book
it takes the exoplanet just under five
days to complete
one orbit of its star that's something
we'll have to get used to
as it takes earth 365
days to orbit the sun time flies right
okay it sounds good but what's the catch
i feel like our space realtor didn't
tell us something
is it haunted well it's worse
tea gardens star b is tidally locked
tidally locked means it takes the same
amount of time for
a planet to spin once about its axis
as it does to orbit once about its star
that means that one side will always
face the warming glow of the star
while the other side faces the bleak
perpetual darkness of space
boy that escalated quickly
one side of the planet will be scorching
hot and the other
in a deep freeze that means
depending on which part we settle on
we'll be trapped in a never-ending day
or night
and way to bury the lead space realtor
so after hearing all that maybe we took
our planet for granted
sure earth has its problems but
we're in a nice habitable zone and our
planet is
full of rich ecosystems maybe
we should treat the earth like a
fixer-upper
and take care of it instead of looking
for planet b
but all this talk about space travel has
us thinking
what if we settled on moons instead of
planets
what if we settled on titan
well that's a story for another
what if